قبل قمه بلدان مجموعه السابع قامت منظمه
اوكسفان بعمليه جرد للديون التي كانت
ستتحملها الدول الغنيه تجاه البلدان
الفقيره
وقالت ان الدول مجموعه السبع مدينه لدول
الجنوب بدين ضخم تبلغ قيمته 13
تريليون دولار العمليه الحسابيه الفريده
من نوعها اخذت بعين الاعتبار ما قالت انه
تراكم للتعهدات التي لم يتم الوفاء بها
لتعويض الخسائر التي تسببت فيها انبعاثات
اكسيد الكربون في بلدان الجنوب
وفي تفاصيل هذا الجر لديونه الدول الغنيه
تقول اوكسفان ان دول مجموعه السبع فشلت في
الوفاء بتعهداتها بتقديم مئه مليار دولار
سنويا حتى عام
لمساعده البلدان الفقيره على التكيف مع
تغير المناخ كمان انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون الخاص بها كانت
ستسبب خسائر بقيمه حوالي تسعه تريليون
تريليونات دولار في البلدان المنخفضه
والمتوسطه الدخل دعت منظمه اوكسفان
حكوماتي مجموعه السبع الى الغاء ديون
البلدان المنخفضه والمتوسطه الدخل ثم
العوده الى نسبه
0.7% من مساعدات الدخل القوميه الاجمالي
وكذلك الوفاء بالتزاماتها لمكافحه التغير
المناخي وتشير تقديرات منظمه
الى حوالي
27 ترليون دولار اضافيه حتى عام 2030 لسد
فجوات التمويل
ياتي للمفارقه في وقت تطالب فيه دول
مجموعه السبع
ونصر مصرفيوها الاثرياء بان تدفع دول
الجنوب
232 مليون دولار يوميا لسداد ديونها حتى
عام
ومن هو المدي